Hello, everybody and welcome to another python 3 basics video in this video. We're going to be discussing the basics of a python function
the idea of a function is to assign a set of code and possibly variables known as parameters to a single bit of
Text so [you] can think of it a lot like why you choose to
Write and save a program rather than writing out the entire program every time you want to execute it or in a much smaller scale
Why we use variables?
So to begin a function you define the function
By using the Keyword Def [d]. [ef] short for Define?
in this notifies python of the impending function definition
From there you're going to type out whatever name you want to refer to your function as now you want to be kind of careful
in the name of your function
just like you would want to be careful in the name of your variable you want to choose something unique, and it's not going to
conflict with anything else like
Time now if you define a function
And you call the time it's going to conflict with the time module should you use it so you don't want to use time?
so for us, we're just going to use example and
after the definition of the functions name you have
The parentheses and within the parentheses you have any parameters if you have any parameters that is
For now, we're just gonna leave those empty, but I will show you guys in some future videos
how to use parameters after
The [parentheses] you [have] a colon and the you hit enter and basically everything you type under here is
Going to be your function block so as you type code
And you hit enter you've got this is all contained in your function
And then finally when you come over here and start typing more code that's outside of the function
[so] this is the function so that's kind of the idea of python standards whereas other programming languages generally you're going to have
curly Braces and you type within the curly braces and blah blah blah
[we] use just indent and indent only so for example. We're just going to say print
basic function
And then we'll actually you know call a bear or assign a variable that's going to be 3 plus 9 and
We'll even print that variable out when we call this function
And that's basically it
now if we go to run this program
You'll find that nothing happens
[so] [we] hit run and nothing happens now sometimes just like trips people up, and what's happened is we've defined the function
But we've not actually
called the function into
Action so to do that you can either type it out, so example empty parameters hit enter and it says basic function [12]
Another thing that you can do is literally within your script you can type out example
And when you go to run it it will just automatically run so you don't have to actually type it in yourself
[so] [this] is the function basics
in the next video what we're going to be talking about is parameters in the function because parameters add quite a bit of
dynamic variability to your function
So that's what we're going to talk about in the next video
Stay tuned for that as always. Thanks for watching thanks [for] all the support and subscriptions and until next time